we now have everything from saved
lives is cooked and it looks
really great and also tastes really good
[applause]
[music]
we are committed to ensuring that this
food is used again,
that it is fed back into the
cycle  and that people also understand
what it's all about
[music]
[applause]
i'm part of coaching because i
think far too much edible
food is thrown away
and i want to do something about it and that's why it's
nice and that's why i also use  the
distributors and I would also like to show him
how sustainable
food handling works
[applause]
[music]
completely open everyone can participate and
everyone can get involved it is very
important for us that we are a participatory
movement
[music]
[applause]
[Music]